[Music]
he was one of the most influential
figures of the 20th century forever
changing the course of one of the
world's largest countries but was he a
hero who toppled an oppressive tyranny
or a villain who replaced it with
another it's time to put Lenin on the
stand in history versus Lenin order
order
now wasn't it your fault that the band
broke up Your Honor this is vladimir
Ilyich Ulyanov aka Lenin the rabble
rouser who helped overthrow the russian
tsar nicholas ii in 1917 and founded the
Soviet Union one of the worst
dictatorships of the 20th century Lazar
was a bloody tyrant under whom the
masses toiled in slavery this is rubbish
serfdom had already been abolished in
1861 and replaced by something worse the
factory bosses treated the people far
worse than the former feudal landlords
and unlike the landlords they were
always there Russian workers toiled for
11 hours a day and were the lowest paid
in all of Europe but Tsar Nicholas made
laws to protect the workers for it it
looked at Lee did the bare minimum to
avert revolution and even there he
failed remember what happened in 1905
after his troops fired on peaceful
petitioners yes and the Tsar ended the
rebellion by introducing a constitution
and an elected parliament the Duma
well retaining absolute power and
dissolving them whenever he wanted
perhaps there would have been more
reforms in due time if radicals like
Lenin weren't always stirring up trouble
your honor Lenin had seen his older
brother Alexander executed by the
previous r4 a revolutionary activity and
even after the reforms Nikolas continued
the same mass oppression and executions
as well as the unpopular involvement in
world war one that costs Russia so many
lives and resources yes
doesn't sound like such a capital fellow
your honor maybe nicholas ii did doom
himself with bad decisions but Lenin
deserves no credit for this when the
February 1917 uprisings finally forced
the Tsar to abdicate Lenin was still
exiled in Switzerland so who came to
power the Duma formed a provisional
government led by Alexander Kerensky an
incompetent bourgeois failure he even
launched another failed offensive in the
war whether or Russia had already lost
so much instead of ending it like the
people wanted it was a constitutional
social democratic government the most
progressive of its time and it could
have succeeded eventually if Lenin
hadn't returned in April sent by the
Germans to undermine the Russian war
effort and instigate riots such slander
the July days were a spontaneous and
justified reaction against the
government's failures and Kerensky
showed his true colors when he blamed
Lenin and arrested and outlawed his
Bolshevik Party forcing him to flee into
exile again some democracy it's a good
thing the government collapsed under
their own incompetence and greed when
they tried to stage a military coup then
had to ask the Bolsheviks for help when
it backfired
after vet all Lenin had to do was a
return in October and take charge the
government was peacefully overthrown
overnight but what the Bolsheviks did
after gaining power wasn't very peaceful
how many people did they execute without
trial and was it really necessary to
murder the Tsar's entire family even the
children Russia was being attacked by
foreign imperialists trying to restore
the Tsar any royal heir that was rescued
would be recognized as a ruler by
foreign governments it would have been
the end of everything the people had
fought so hard to achieve
besides when and may not have given the
order but it was not only imperialists
that the Bolsheviks killed what about
the purges and executions of other
socialist and anarchist parties their
old allies what about the Tambov
rebellion where peasants resisting grain
confiscation were killed with poison gas
or sending the army to crush the workers
in Kronstadt who were demanding
democratic self-management was this
still fighting for the people yes the
measures were difficult but it was a
difficult time the new government needed
to secure itself while being attacked
from all sides so that the socialist
order could be established and what good
came of this socialist order even after
the civil war was won there were famines
repression and millions executed or sent
to die in camps while Lenin's successor
Stalin established a cult of personality
and absolute power set
wasn't the plan Lenin never cared for
personal gains even his enemies admitted
that he fully believed in his cause
living modestly and working tirelessly
from his student days until his to early
death he saw how power-hungry Stalin was
and tried to warn the party but it was
too late and the decades of
totalitarianism that followed after you
can call it that but it was Lenin's
efforts that changed Russia in a few
decades from a backward and undeveloped
monarchy full of illiterate peasants to
a modern industrial superpower with one
of the world's best educated populations
on presidented opportunities for women
and some of the most important
scientific advancements of the century
life may not have been luxurious but
nearly everyone had a roof over their
head and food on their plate which few
countries have achieved but these
advances could still have happened even
without Lenin and the repressive regime
he established yes and I could have been
a famous rock and roll singer but how
would I have sounded
we can never be sure how things could
have unfolded if different people were
in power or different decisions were
made but to avoid the mistakes of the
past we must always be willing to put
historical figures on trial
[Music]